and sustainability,
repopulating endangered species and environmental restoration.
Inmates can be scientists and beekeepers,
dog rescuers.
Prisons can be the source of meaningful work
and opportunity for staff
and the inmates who live there.
We can contain and control
and provide humane environments.
These are not opposing qualities.
We can't wait 10 to 20 years to find out
if this is worth doing.
Our strategy is not massive system change.
Our strategy is hundreds of small changes
that take place in days or months, not years.
We need more small pilots where we learn as we go,
pilots that change the range of possibility.
We need new and better ways to measure impacts
on engagement, on interaction,
on safe environments.
We need more opportunities to participate in
and contribute to our communities,
your communities.
Prisons need to be secure, yes, safe, yes.
We can do that.
Prisons need to provide humane environments
where people can participate, contribute,
and learn meaningful lives.
We're learning how to do that.
That's why I'm hopeful.
We don't have to stay stuck in old ideas about prison.
We can define that. We can create that.
And when we do that thoughtfully and with humanity,
prisons can be more than the bucket
for failed social policy.
Maybe finally, we will earn our title:
a department of corrections.
Thank you.
(Applause)